hey nina what's up hey tom real quick
the 20th anniversary of the harry potter
movies just happened and so and do you
want a synopsis of the stories no i no
problem fights voldemort fights
voldemort hangs out with his dad's
friend from high school who just got out
of jail fights voldemort fights
voldemort dumbledore eats it fights
voldemort no that's not technically
wrong but hey i can go into more detail
please don't but it's gonna take a while
and i don't know if you're gonna be able
to keep up i reread all the books every
year i know so much more than you do
we'll start with harry's infancy oh [ __ ]
it is a dark time for wizard kind as the
evil lord voldemort has become what
sorcerers refer to as a jerk mcgurk oh
yeah a jerk who must not be named a
prophecy states that voldemort will be
defeated by
some kid oversimplification so he
decides to kill baby harry by feeding
him to a snake nope uh by chucking him
out a window no by unbaby-proofing the
potter house and letting him title into
corners no he uses magic he uses magic
to try to stop a prophecy isn't that
sort of like begging for ironic
narrative retribution i don't know what
to tell you every baby looks like a nail
when all you've got is a magic hammer
yeah a hammer would've worked moving on
because harry's mom sacrifices herself
to save him harry is granted powerful
magical protection that's correct it's
just like how that secret service agent
died protecting president truman and now
he's our immortal bulletproof president
for life
sure so voldemort gets turned into a
problem for later also harry winds up
with some of voldemort's soul in his
tummy so now he can talk to snakes oh
and also his forehead glows when orcs
are near close enough harry grows up
with his aunt and uncle and cousin who
are the bad guys from every role doll
book until his 11th birthday when he
finds out that he has magic powers and
goes shopping for a stick that shoots
fire and can kill people then it's off
to elementary school
[Music]
book one ends with harry and his friends
doing the british version of legends of
the hidden temple and harry fighting the
back of his teacher's head
uh-huh book two is a classic murder
mystery where the culprit is a racist
snake book 3 is a classic british time
travel caper in the tradition of doctor
who and the worst episodes of doctor who
now this is also the book where fans get
upset when they find out that the rat
that ron has been sharing a bed with for
years was actually a middle-aged man but
what they never seem to mention is
whether it would have been less weird if
he had just been sleeping next to a
regular rat right yeah marginally less
weird book four marks an important tonal
shift for harry after being chosen to
compete in what's essentially the magic
olympics let me stop you right there the
tri-wizard tournament is not the magic
olympics okay what would you compare it
to it's more like the wizard ncaa only
there's a chance the athletes might
actually get paid got it anyway harry
watches his ron's old pet rat turns his
classmate cedric diggory
into dedrick diggory
he turns him into a grave diggery
in the dedrick grave diggery dead murder
dead please stop voldemort comes back
first is an angry little baby then has a
long white jelly bean great in year five
harry learns that government oversight
is bad and that starting a fight club at
school is good meanwhile voldemort hears
the first half of a prophecy about
himself and he gets all self-conscious
so he gaslights harry into visiting a
snow globe factory yeah
wait what so then harry finds out that
he's half dracula and then my dad shows
up and he's all like you're the reason
your mom left and after that pete
davidson takes his pants tom what you
fell asleep during the movie yeah that
makes more sense all right where was i
giving me an aneurysm year six is a
tough one because in the books it's an
exploration of trauma and betrayal and
their effects on young people whereas in
the movie harry does kissing oh an
attempted homicide also the teacher that
harry thought was bad turns out to be
bad okay perfect go on in the last book
harry and his friends do a scavenger
hunt for wads of voldemort's soul and
also the teacher that harry thought was
bad that turned out to be bad turns out
to not be so bad at all just super duper
horny for harry's mom always voldemort
dies of a flaky peely sunburn everyone
marries someone that they went to high
school with and the story's over so what
about the cursed child rupert grint well
first of all he's not cursed he just has
red hair never mind so there you have it
the story of a bullied young white boy
who grew up to be a cop get his best
friend's sister pregnant look you're not
wrong but that's not why i called i
already know all of this in fact i know
way more than this so wait you knew
everything that was being said but you
sat through it anyway even though you
were just getting bored and mad yeah
fans call that the fantastic beasts
effect okay why did you call i want to
see if i could borrow your gryffindor
robes i'm going to a costume party oh um
those are still at the dry cleaner wait
why
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no reason